you guys it has been a crazy week in
america so let's find out what happened
as a health precaution for in-person
hearings supreme court justices have
reportedly stopped shaking hands ahead
of oral arguments instead from now on
they'll just touch butts
your honor your honor your honor pink
was that that blow back
that was how that when i whipped my butt
around oh by the time it got you
ah okay it's loose
your honor
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry the nra board
of directors recently re-elected the
group's controversial leader and he
seems pretty happy about it
[Applause]
the pandemic has reportedly led to a
shortage of clowns in northern ireland
it turns out they're down to only one
astrophysicist neil degrasse tyson
turned 63 this week but
if you think about it
the universe was born 13.8 billion years
ago
which is what the last 18 months have
felt like during this pandemic
if we condense that time down to one
covid calendar year one month equals
more than one billion years one day
equals 40 million years as the world
shut down it was quarantined for
200 million years the january 6th
insurrection formed 11 billion years ago
in this scale modern civilization didn't
start getting vaccinated until the last
14 seconds of the year
all that to say my last two birthdays
don't count moving on
40.
i just turned 40.
the cdc recently published a list of
safety tips for celebrating the holidays
like keeping a window open so that if
someone comes to your house unvaccinated
you can throw them out of it
come to my house
hey
you and your facebook yeah
you don't take your crazy ass on off
that window
i
can't wait i can't wait for you to
actually have to i mean
i will angrily to protect my parents
[Applause]
man beats entire family with ass with
ass
oh he beat him with pizzazz
yes that too
a florida mansion owned by the maker of
the cabbage patch kids was recently
listed for sale for nearly 13 million
dollars the property comes with a pool a
gym and a seriously messed up garden
gross don't
don't look into them garbage pails
oh
no
no no
no to you and no to your reaction
everybody is bad today i won't have it
scientists have recently developed a
device that treats depression by sending
electrical pulses to the brain
guys just call it a vibrator
and finally a strike was held this week
by workers at the food company kellogg
apparently their working conditions
aren't great
[Applause]
and that was the monologue did you like
the motherhood
i am glad to hear that yes no
it's officially october which means many
areas across the country are reaching
something called peak week that's when
fall foliage is at its most colorful
well
we here at the amber ruffin show are
also in the midst of a stunning seasonal
display of beauty it's called peak
wall-e
as you can see
our cue card guy wally has begun his
annual transition away from summer and
into fall and needless to say it's
remarkable to behold for a precious
short window of time wally will dress
exclusively in cashmere cardigans plaid
button-ups and fingerless gloves
in addition while these few cards have
begun to change color first to a vibrant
orange then to a lustrous red and
finally to an earthy brown and once his
cue cards start changing colors they
are absolutely gorgeous cue cards by the
way and they have started showing jokes
about pumpkin spice lattes like this
i like pumpkin spice a latte now those
are not the jokes we asked him to print
but
during peak wally those are the only
jokes he can physically print and of
course it wouldn't be peak wally without
a constant stream of enraptured tourists
flocking to the studio to catch a
glimpse of his splendor
oh my god it's peak wall-e absolutely
stunning
now i should note that wally is not in
control of this process he reaches peak
wally every year whether he wants to or
not and i also want to stress that peak
wally will not last forever it's a
fleeting natural process so drink it in
while you still have the chance
wow pink wally
so
if you're interested in seeing pete
wally throw the family into the van and
head down to 30 rock
in other news
last weekend more than
126 000 gallons of oil was spilled into
the pacific ocean in southern california
efforts to undo this damage are gonna uh
no
sorry
no i don't want to do anything about
this yeah i don't want to think about
this at all
because you see
some news gives me the roots
some news makes me feel pissed
but some news is just so bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist
thousands upon thousands of gallons of
oil in the pacific ocean
that just doesn't exist
some news fills me with joy
some news fills me with this
but some news is just so bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist like this in a
recent instagram post singer shakira
revealed that she was attacked in a park
in barcelona by wild boars now the
thought of this happening to shakira
someone i deeply love no i'm gonna
pretend like that news story does not
exist is that a healthy derek nothing i
do is healthy
that just doesn't exist
some news i'll take
[Music]
news i just dismissed
but some news is just so bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist like this
several plant-based meat companies have
hit the market recently with new
plant-based fish
alternative seafood is one of the
fastest growing segments of that
industry mating
people eat that
no that just doesn't exist
it doesn't exist
no baby it doesn't exist no no no baby
it doesn't exist
that news doesn't exist i have my own
youtube channel now yay be sure to
subscribe for a lot of show clips and a
lot of digital exclusives and a lot of
this
you